alou votre président à l'appareil mon
président et non trois présidents plus
garderai ce numéro exclusivement pour
cette mission émission existe trois mois
parce que j'ai totale confiance
concernant pour écouter les autres que
je vais vous dire vous participez à des
missions d'étape
tenez vous prêts avant l'intervention de
mes deux bleus vers moi je savoure cette
entreprise terroriste être mises en
échec
j'ai rien volé j'appelle je demande
poliment de l'argent vous envoie j'ai
quand même pas pu ouvrir toutes ces
boîtes ultra sécurisés comme des
concerts juste avec mon téléphone ou
alors les escrocs c'est ceux qui sont
payés pour sécuriser des banques à ce
que vous pensez de tenir le coup il
retourne et est comment va ta mère
versez votre collaboration
si tu commences à me soupçonnait en
permanence mon séjour j'ai fait
confiance
sur un beau poisson quoi tu prends des
risques à la con tu veux qui m'arrive
noob les yeux la lune efficace at on pas
enfin mal fini
non pas cette offre je sais faire quoi
donc
le moins de chance
pour votre sécurité vous je pense que
vous feriez mais d'entraînement en
france
l'armé la plus dangereuse du monde tout
ce que je veux c'est arrêter un peu plus
tranquille c'est normal dans le cerveau
ne pas te laisser faire ça je te laisse
savoir qu'est votre prise celui qui
décroche